all right james yes james where'd you
grow up where are you from originally uh
originally east coast uh northeast
boston area
and tell me about how you grew up you
had mom and dad yeah mom and dad uh were
they met during the vietnam war they met
in a uh
army
testing facility and i've been together
ever since still together
moved out to los angeles
and
they live here currently
how would you describe your childhood
childhood was amazing i was not
i would educate anything education in
sports was funded everything else was
earned and very well dished out i would
i would say i could not blame any of my
sexual predilections or any of my issues
whatsoever on my parents they they loved
each other they never fought they um
they they kissed they cuddled they
discussed things like adults there was
never any violence in the family
um it was it was wonderful nothing else
happened to you outside the family
when you were a kid
yes that did happen um when i was so i
have two virginity dates or loss of
virginity dates because
um
i thought
it was at 16 when i had
was with my thin girlfriend from high
school
however
after some therapy i realized that
i had suppressed a memory that when i
was 15 working at a summer camp i was at
the first party of the summer and it was
the first time i had really been drunk i
had about
12 rolling rocks and over the course of
eight hours playing king's cup for the
first time
which was all fun and then um the next
thing i know the girls showed up and uh
a lot of them were really with me and i
was just having a lot of fun and
one of the older counselors one of the
senior counselors a female she was 23
she led me up into an upstairs bedroom
and she basically threw me on the floor
and just started making out with me and
then tore my clothes off
and
i had no idea what to think she was
kind of what everyone in the camp called
the butterface and um she had a great
body but um
wasn't wasn't the most beautiful thing
in the world but not those ugly either
and apparently i was aroused by it
because when she pulled my pants off my
penis was quite direct and so she was
started talking very dirty and
went down on me and then the next thing
i know she just gets up on her feet and
starts squatting and she's
putting me inside her and riding me and
then
as if that weren't enough then all of a
sudden the girl that i had a crush on
that was more my age appropriate uh came
into the room to watch and sat in the
corner and was pleasuring herself while
that went down so um of an experience
for a 15 year old yeah the interesting
thing though was after processing it
and asking a friend about it at the time
who had a vague recollection he said
initially you were quite like proud of
it
and you didn't really give me details
and then i guess because i was so drunk
and like whatever i
totally forgot about it suppressed it
and then my therapist brought it out she
was really good
and of course she had to be this
extremely smoking hot
very smart asian dressed like with the
sexy skirts and she was constantly
sucking on candy the whole time which
was driving me crazy because it was very
oral fixation kind of thing and
and yeah and i was just all i did had
transference issues and just wanted to
think about bending her over the desk so
anyway
she uh said to me she said well david
this can't come as that much of a shock
to you i mean it's not like you're going
to be satisfied with monogamous
missionary once a week sex for the rest
of your life so
i thought that was pretty telling about
my sexual past and history and where it
went from there and
how it got started and everything like
that and
where i'm at today so
and where where's where do you think
that's led your sexual appetite and
desires and
to
all sorts of kinks and fetishes or
taboos or whatever you would call that
are
within the frame of the law and
do not include bdsm
and pain
or
bodily fluids that are not naturally
occurring during sex
[Laughter]
um
i uh the parameters of would you like
like the scattering of some of the
things that sure
well uh for instance uh in college uh
later in college towards the end a
friend of mine told me admitted to me
that he had been working as a as a
high-end uh
escort on the side
for um for madame who was based out of
beverly hills a lot of um
a lot of uh divorced milfs and uh widows
and things like that and
then there was it was mostly for women
but there was you know there were a few
guys that like wanted to take you out on
dates and then would like really try
hard to turn you and anyway um i decided
to try it and um
with the exception of like doing the uh
the like the striptease kind of party
things because i'm not that great a
dancer
um
and i just never really saw myself as a
chippendales kind of guy but i
rather enjoyed it and
went to a lot of cool charity functions
and
benefits and uh
sporting events and operas and um
then
it was like no pressure to do anything
because it was well known it was a legit
you know
agency but um
there were definite times when
i was offered quite a bit to
perform sexually um and there were times
when i did it for free because i was
so attracted well not free i i was
always getting paid there was a set you
know price but um there were times when
i was so attracted because one of my
kinks is is milfs and older women
and uh that i would just do it and
sometimes i would even spend the entire
night with him
and
do all sorts of things but basically my
um
my main i guess my main kink would be
not that kinky but it's like whatever
places a woman i'm into as long as it
doesn't involve those things you know so
um
yeah there are some
normal-ish
appearing people that have a lot of
things that they do in the bedroom that
would surprise you do you think this is
a lot more common than we all assume
very much more common than everyone
knows yes
yeah
yes
absolutely what other kind of things
have you gotten into
uh since escorting or during that time
or in general in your life i mean that's
how you've had a variety of i've had i
mean there's so many things i can't even
i don't even know where to begin but
what gets you into these situations is
it your curiosity and desire for for it
yeah it was uh
it was friday night you're out looking
for something fun to happen
usually i mean i i'm not i i'm not uh i
don't consider myself a quote unquote
sex addict i'm not like trying riskier
and riskier and riskier things and and
trying and every night and that sort of
thing like you know what would you
describe yourself as
um someone once brought mentioned the
term sexual compulsionist and i kind of
liked that because it's like
it brings the psychology into it of it
like you know addict is so you know
just no
common nomenclature but there's
dependency there's addiction there's
compulsions there's you know obsessions
i think i'm more obsessed than anything
and then they lead to some compulsions i
watched a lot of porn growing up i stole
my dad's collection so like for instance
my first [ __ ] i think most people in
america
red-blooded americans i would imagine
just kind of sit back and lie back and
let the girl do the thing but of course
know me what did i do i had watched so
much porn i straddled her face and like
basically
i don't know if i'm allowed to curse or
anything here but i have at it face you
know and then of course i
was like super excited by it and like
really turned on and didn't last that
long and then
i
wasn't sure what to do with my
um
you know
ejaculate and so i just decided well
she's got nice breasts and so i just
covered it with them and i was just like
in seventh heaven and then i was like
felt guilty
for a minute and i went immediately went
down on her and and then she just said
do you want more and i was like
okay
so like that's that's like really where
it got started and then you know it's
in order to um
to say where it's led from there i you
know in college i i uh i really started
to uh
to blossom because like the first girl
that i met in college and had sex with
was there early um she was very bright
and she was uh technically
almost 17 and i was 18
and um so she i think she was 16
technically but like almost 17 and like
it was it was that was i she didn't tell
me before and i was like oh geez you
know is this
but it was kind of hot at the same time
and um
from there it uh
it it just it took off and i played
hockey in college and there were a lot
of groupies
and um so for instance like my first
threesome
was with this groupie who she wanted to
develop a reward system for me scoring
goals and getting assists and stuff and
so she uh we got i got i got so good and
i got so far ahead of points that one
one day after that one night after the
game
uh i come home into my bedroom and it's
her and two other sorority girls and
they're topless in my bed
and um
you can imagine where it led from there
so it was uh that's motivation to score
yeah and she was she was enough in and
of herself because she was a dynamo
and she did not have any daddy issues
that's for sure so
um she was very comfortable with
everything and like it was
it was amazing i mean the other two
girls were mostly there for aesthetics
but like
things started to happen and so
i was like wow this is awesome
threesomes are awesome so the porn you
know world was then was videotapes and
things like that and you know um
then the next year
i got a girlfriend who i had for a few
years who
ended up being
very much a nymphomaniac and one time
the entire team watched from the rooftop
and filmed while we went at it
and i didn't know
and then she noticed them and looked out
and saw what was going on and got all
embarrassed and pissed and like i had to
go out and then yell at them and pretend
that i was mad and then i was like
whispered okay did you get any good
footage and can we put it up and so it
was it was really hot to be filmed and
be watched like that and i think that's
where my first
exhibitionism
came in
because i really like to
have sex with other people watching and
one of my favorite memories of all time
is when
i was invited with my my
fiance at the time
to go to palm springs for vacation for a
swinger's party in a very big suite and
basically there was about
i don't know 10 to 12 groups of married
swingers that were there older
and
just
a big bed set up in the middle and like
i just was so
drunk and
high on blow and so excited turned on i
like
went into beast mode and
everyone was just like enthralled with
how
well i was able to perform and like so
many of the the couples came up to me
and asked if they would if i could play
with them later or if i could do this do
that and
so um but my girlfriend was her and
fiance with time was insanely jealous of
me being with any other girl so
you know
that sort of thing
ended up happening later so has this
lifestyle enriched your life or is it
caused more problems than
well
um
it's enriched it when i've been single
but then again it's also harder
as a single male in
the world the lifestyle whatever you
want to call it um
it's
definitely
ruined a relationship um but that was a
very toxic relationship as well and i
feel like if it hadn't been that way
um things would have been different but
i mean
you know stepping out to go and
screw an escort is one thing because
i've i've dated three and before that
i've you know it was no big deal to me
you know so
um and i really enjoyed it and each one
was different a different experience and
it was
not love but it was
mutual affection and
it was
work and on the weekends i would do my
regular job and on the weekends like i
would try to work with them because they
didn't want to go and but they needed
money and so
you know
it was amazing how many of them were
able to pull like couples that were
willing to like do like full swap or
soft swap or whatever you know or just
watch us you know and you're employed
you have a job yeah yeah you're yes
you're a working man and you
normally yeah right now because kovid
kind of ruined my
uh current job to where it's at a
part-time and so i'm applying for other
things and i have this
silly uh well
maybe not silly but just
i kind of have this uh
fantasy of just becoming a
somewhat-ish
known
amateur porn star because i used to have
a lot of videos i like videotaping
myself and watching it and stuff and um
unfortunately i was hacked and
everything was not backed up properly
and
pornhub had all my content and then just
dumped it so
you know i had some good stuff there too
so with your square jobs as sex come
into play when you're working
um
not so much um i it's pretty
professional so
yeah i mean
i won't lie like there have been
you know
clients that you know have expressed
interest and
have done things that were overtly
sexual and
kind of inappropriate and i had to like
really bite my teeth on that and
certain times i may have may not have
crossed the line i'm can't really
disclose that information but um
they're
i mean
i got to witness a lot working as a
paramedic of other people's kinks and
fetishes and things and stuff especially
in in west hollywood where i worked it
was it was very interesting
uh
probably the best
craziest unbelievable story ever but
it's 100 too true it was a random
thursday night and
cold and it was like 3 30 a.m and when
you get called out at 3 30 am it's never
anything good it's never like a
toothache or anything [ __ ] like that
either
so we get to the street and it's all
dark and it was an unknown medical aid
and whenever they do that or whenever
they used to do that way back they would
always send a sheriff unit too so
we pull up onto the to the address and
this six foot six like really skinny guy
in boxer shorts comes running up to the
uh the ambulance and we rolled i rolled
down the window i was writing shotgun
i'm like can i help you he goes she did
not overdose i said okay where's she at
so the engine company the squad us and
the sheriff go up these narrow stairs
into this little apartment and we go to
open the door bang hit something
what was that and the guy's like hold on
hold on hold on and he sneaks in and he
doesn't move something around and he
opens the door and they're lying right
in front of the door is a woman
completely naked except for a g-string
her arm is in a cast full full cast with
a bar attached to the side here okay
syringe in the arm tourniquet's still
tied and not breathing i'm like oh jesus
i'm like what are you shooting heroin
what do you get you know and they're
like yeah that and math and like okay
okay get that out of her arm i started
breathing for they were getting the line
in her to give her the narcan to reverse
it and the ox just the oxygenation woke
her up and she's
lazarus effect kind of thing and then
she goes
but there's a vibrator in my [ __ ] and
we all laugh and we're like okay
whatever you know so we got her loaded
up and like she kept saying on the way
to the hospital she was obtunded but she
wasn't completely
you know
not not non-verbal and she kept saying
but there's a vibrator in my business
there's a vibrator in my [ __ ] and the
guy riding in the back with me just in
case things got hairy again with thought
he was funny like well why do you have a
vibrator and [ __ ] and she's like me and
my boyfriend were gonna have kinky sex
and i'm like i just don't have time for
this i'm too tired so my partner gets
out to pull her out at the hospital and
he does kind of looks like this and he's
like dave there's a vibrator in her
[ __ ] i'm like pete stop you you just
you you're not funny let's just take her
inside so we take her inside the nurse
checks her out and says why is she still
clothed and like
i don't undress women who are
anyway she cuts off the underwear and lo
and behold mind you i'm 18 19. i've
never seen a vibrator before in my life
really up close and this one had
something that i'd
still yet to really see again it had
there was definitely a vibrational there
was a wire coming out of it leading to a
switch then another wire that led to one
that was in her anus
and the nurse freaked out said why
didn't you take that out i i quickly
said oh because in in l.a county uh
we're not allowed to remove impaled
objects
now they're talking about things like
sticks in your arm and stuff like that
but anyway so we chuckled at that she
went and lubed up grabbed the vibrator
pulled it out in doing so turned it on
to the point where it was shaking like
crazy and she freaks out and screams and
she throws it and it skids across the er
floor
only to hit the leg of a sleeping mother
of a child that we had brought in before
with a broken leg playing soccer she
wakes up and screams the kid wakes up
and screams he doesn't know what the
hell he's looking at other nurses start
screaming and my partner is literally
dying down like this laughing
hysterically like peeing himself
and i just was like
i don't think i'm ever going to be able
to
get anyone to believe that that happened
but that's 100 how it happened and and
in paramedicine and
you know the ems world they always say
never let the truth get in the way of
the good story and it's a lot
embellishment is allowed to you know
one-up someone but this is 100 how it
went down
my big thing is that um
i have
fortunately been fortunate enough to be
the medical knowledge and the access to
care such that i
you've heard of prep for hiv well
there's a lot of other medications you
can take to suppress other things
because
i'm not a big fan of condoms it's just
it's not the same it's a difficult
whatever so
i am very much into
you know what's called bareback and so
that's one of the things that i like i
pretty much
um
not demand but prefer like you know i
always respect what the other person
wants but
so
that's that's one of the things that
that i'm that i'm into but i'm on like
literally meds that no one even thinks
to be preventative like doxycycline
which can prevent syphilis they can
prevent chlamydia it can prevent lyme
disease which they don't know may or may
not be sexually transmitted it's a whole
a whole host of medications so
and um
i've always been negative i test myself
regularly and i think everyone should
even if they're in a monogamous
relationship you never know what's going
on
because you know
i
in my last relationship i was
definitely
i mean we both cheated it was a toxic
relationship but you know
i was turned on by that and that that
was a thing you know um
and so
when you were asking if it negatively
affected my yeah
because i felt bad but like
when we finally broke up you know she's
like i could handle the [ __ ] but like i
just couldn't uh i couldn't handle you
like going and like you know falling for
someone else because
i went and i sought you know
treatment for depression and anxiety and
things that i was compensating for with
sex you know and um i just realized that
like
you know all the fighting in that
relationship no matter how good the sex
was and how much she was willing to
swing and
have other guys have threesomes with her
and other girls like for example like
for my birthday she got me this escort
that i picked out who was blonde and
young and was from missouri i believe
and
had a [ __ ] stamp that said rich [ __ ]
on it
and had like a dog collar tattoo and all
sorts of great stories and loved xanax
and cocaine and like
it was just
it was just
the time of my life like you know
watching her go down on my girlfriend
actually making her orgasm than
getting a [ __ ] from her and then
i even was like
i know you said baby that you couldn't
have sex because you said no go ahead
and so like i was like doing rails off
of her butt while i was nailing her from
behind and it was just like the time in
my life so
you know
this is with
the help of
my ex-girlfriend yeah no but drugs are
part of your life
drugs are a part of my life because i
have a lot of psychiatric issues and so
i'll always be on medicine in terms of
elicits i am
uh it used to be a bigger part yeah and
now i'm trying to
um curb that as much as possible um
because of many very many factors um
you know i'm i'm trying to
um
[Music]
i'm trying to establish a
a healthy relationship um where she
allows me to
have sex with other people as long as
she watches so
that satisfies that
um and then the use of elicits is
reduced but i still have a fetish i
guess for
girls who like to
use you know certain substances
to enhance the experience
um no the crystal is like not actually
my favorite i mean it'll do the trick
and it depending on what it is it can be
very very good or it can just be like me
but um
i always i always preferred just
surrounding myself in a room with even
even if it was just my ex-girlfriend
just in a room with some pizza as you
would call it but it was
code for cocaine and um you know just
having a night together and just having
lots of sex but like
it uh it also led to you know threesomes
and things like that and then um
ecstasy but not molly i don't get molly
i don't understand it when younger
people explain it to me i've never had a
good experience with it
and so
yeah
i uh i don't mess with opiates at all
because of the dangers and because i had
a shoulder injury and was on them
pharmaceutically for years so
um
i don't want to go that route again so
fortunately i'm out of pain and i'm off
of them so do you think that
experience you had when you were 15 at
the camp yeah kind of steered you in
this direction yeah absolutely because
when i tell people about it
and like
it's like
i'm like
i honestly i freaking loved it
when i if i'm honest about it like i
freaking loved it like
i mean it was it was like a scene in a
porno it was just
it was unreal and then like
you know she
she got me again when i was
i realized this later
but i had blacked out several times but
then
she took me again
in another room
in front of other people
so
it was
i don't remember that part i'm just told
that
but
you know um but i have been
raped before uh where
it was not so much fun
um
i think it was g or something
and um i'm not really sure what happened
and
it was
women and possibly men i don't know
um
kind of woke up in the middle of it and
then went back to sleep
and then one time someone one time a guy
did try to
rape me with by slipping g into
the alcohol i was drinking so
um
not so much a big fan of that anymore
but it didn't
fortunately i wasn't nothing happened
because i
i came to so
has this lifestyle this this
this
curiosity or attraction you have for
this lifestyle impaired your ability to
have a loving relationship
yeah or are there partners that are cool
with it no so yes see that's the thing
that's the key there are
and
look everyone's gonna have their hard
limits there's you no matter how kinky
or [ __ ] or whatever you are you say
you're online there's someone's gonna
have a hard limit you know and like for
me that's just like you know certain
things like i'm not going to have sex
with another man and i'm not going to
have him have sex with me it's not going
to happen you know has a penis
inadvertently ended up in my mouth
during a threesome sure was it a big
deal no big deal uh was it were there
are there women out there who enjoy
when you're doing it with their husband
or whatever that maybe there's a little
bit of mail mail play
yeah whatever i could take it or leave
it inherently it for me it does nothing
but like if again it comes back to
pleasing women
because i felt like i was so
brought into it
so well ish
what what other what other kind of
areas does this fascination take you in
i mean what are your
um i've i've never had a sexual
encounter i've come close with like uh
transsexuals and they seem to be drawn
to me or something i'm not really sure
what the deal is there um but it's
always it was it was crazy to me the one
time i went out on a date with this
woman and things got hot and heavy and
all of a sudden boom and i mean and she
was like sculpted perfectly so like that
was that was interesting um and uh she
had a feminine body feminine body like
very nice breasts like the face
everything know it shave that i mean
everything gender reassignment total
hormone replacement and then a huge
penis
yeah totally surprised me you know what
yeah
um the best
that area that this has led to though or
that i missed the most
is my
amazing uncanny trained
a lot of hours spent ability to find the
gems in craigslist so like i'll give you
a perfect example because like a lot of
times it was
it was just feast or famine right and
mostly famine but like this one time i
responded to an ad
it was just said
woman
24
cute blonde having her first gang bang
call for
text and send pick for details and i got
back this like information about where
it's going down what's going on and then
like i asked for a picture and i got
like some barely like you know hear down
blurry kind of thing they're like look
trust me she's cute blah blah and i i
know how to fish out for the most part
the people who are full of it and aren't
and i don't know something about it told
me it was on st patrick's day it was
being hosted by an older swinger couple
and she was a roommate so i show up at
the door i'm first one there i bring
party favors i bring wine i bring money
for the room
and i walk in and there's a gorgeous
swedish i mean she's an la-9 legit
uh girl there
super excited and then there's a a milf
like teacher type
um swinger and her husband just sitting
in the corner watching and like i come
over and i bring the presents you know
over and stuff and give them everything
i even brought um since i didn't i
wasn't able to get the papers for all my
testing i i bought a
rapid hiv one and like as soon as i just
pulled it out did it in front of him
like no he's he's totally clean you
don't have to wear a condom and i was
like cool
and um so we just started going at it
and um
then
apparently like some other guys started
showing up and like you know things were
happening and then one of them happened
to be her boyfriend
and
he i didn't realize that other guys were
like you know having their turn and then
they were finishing and he was quietly
escorting them out and like um
then he's like yeah i just wanted to be
you me her and then the other couple and
so then
the woman that hosting it she got naked
went down started going down on me and
then he comes over and he says when
she's finished i want you to take my
girl the blonde into the bathroom and i
want you to bend her over the sink and i
want you to you know come inside her and
i'm like okay
and
i'm like i don't mind doing it out here
he's like no no go in there have your
time trust me so i did and it was
awesome and then she came out and she
got back on the top of the bed and she
stood on the bed and he went down on her
and sucking my
jacket out of her and
then kissing her back with it and i
thought that that was
unbelievably hot and crazy and wild and
again a story that no one would believe
but like
that it came from craigslist as well too
so
anyways
craigslist has had some amazing finds
i just have to say that
i miss those days
it is it is i mean
there was this one girl who was just i
guess
she i think it ended up being just l.a
oh no yeah no i've been to i've been to
san diego for
for a swap with a wife with like totally
normal people who didn't even do any
drugs they just drank like a little bit
and like you know i've had sober
threesomes and swaps and things like
that i've had i've had pretty much any
type you can imagine like i've been to
gangbangs i don't really like
that them as much but like you know are
drugs usually uh a part of these
encounters
not on a day-to-day basis no not for you
but i'm saying oh like the
that that crowd that is like going on
craigslist trying to find sexual
encounters craigslist sexual encounters
yeah i would say more than not yeah yeah
or were because like there's certain
drugs that will enhance your libido yeah
like um your ability to do it for a
whole night and all that yeah exactly
well you know i i i so one of my
interesting side notes is i uh i lost a
testicle due to cesaro torsion
and so
yeah it was painful but um i uh you lost
away i lost my testosterone sorry i left
my left testicle due to a testicular
torsion oh i see okay when the blood
vessels twist around it and it cuts off
and so they had to remove it and they
put a prosthesis in and it changed my
life forever because my orgasms were
longer increased and i had ability to
have multiple orgasms for some reason
afterwards i don't know why maybe it was
because i got testosterone and cialis
for the rest of my life i don't know but
and then there's tri-mix which
i'm
if you've heard of
caverject
that's like the over-the-counter or
rather the prescription just injectable
trimex is a compounded formula that has
extra stuff in it so if you ever thought
you had a small penis try to do a little
injective try mix and you will be
very impressed with the results
so it's a product endorsement yeah oh
yeah yeah you got to go to a special
compounding pharmacy though all right um
but yeah so yeah certain drugs are
associated with certain
i think
people for of for the most part um you
know men who like to have sex with men
generally are crystal methamphetamine
it's very rare to find those that are
into cocaine whereas you know
more
couples are into
you know like cocaine or ecstasy or
my my escort girlfriend was really into
ketamine
um which scared me because it's a
dissociative anesthetic and i'd
used it clinically and you know i didn't
want to go into a k hole but she just
loved going to these hollywood small you
know she was an amateur porn star ex
escort and and just like getting
into her like zone where she's still
with it but not like
completely
the word like
her
her eyes would glaze over but she was
there and and like
she would get railed by guy after guy
after guy while i sat there and she
would go down on me and like she just
i i she would always keep nodding just
to make sure that she was okay like that
was our thing because
at first it really scared me because i'm
all about consent because i've been
raped and because i think rape is worse
than murder and i think taking the power
away from someone like that so like i'm
all about consensual play 100
so when you're dealing with substances
you there's there are very strict and
very well described california laws as
to
when someone is intoxicated and can't
give consent versus when someone's using
a substance and can give consent and
fortunately i'm very well aware of that
and i practiced that
100
um
so
yeah what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned from this
living this lifestyle
the most important thing that i've
learned is that it will
if if you just
if you just have all if all you're doing
is going and having casual sex and
anonymous or whatever what have you no
strings attached whatever you want to
call it it's going to lead to
pretty much emptiness and depression
when it runs out it's kind of like a
dopamine rush and then it fades you know
it's kind of like crashing off of
crystal or whatever you know so the
thing to do is to find that person
that accepts your kinks or at least meet
you halfway and you can deal with theirs
and you can have a loving relationship
whether it be polyamorous whether it be
you know open whether it be
like like i was part of the throuple for
a while it was
they were partners they were not
boyfriend and girlfriend and uh she was
bisexual he was straight and he loved
having other guys come and and he he
would tell me like i the best thing in
my day would be if i come home from work
and your
guys are banging it out on the couch and
like we had a blast i mean we just and
he was into videotaping and everything i
was and like bareback and everything and
unfortunately they moved to missouri but
if california law would allow me to
marry them i probably would have tried
that but anyway but no it's it's more
about finding that one person that you
can actually truly accept for who they
are as a person as a whole
falling in love staying in love and then
finding the way
to embrace your kink and let it out but
in spurts and in
ways that
respect hard limits
like with my current situation
my partner does not want to have sex or
be touched by another male whatsoever
she has no problem watching me
occasionally have sex with other women
you know and
sometimes she'll even join in with the
other woman
call her bicurious if you will and that
to me is so incredibly hot that like
i don't feel the need to like step out
and like go bang and escort by myself
you know what i mean
and that's
that's
taken a while to get there
you're this is a happy lifestyle for you
you enjoy it
i enjoy aspects of it yes yeah i do
the majority of it yeah i don't enjoy
there's no going back right
there is
i think as you get as you age i mean i
don't know a lot of the swingers i've
met like true swingers and like nudists
and things like a lot of them are old
and happy and they've been doing it for
years you know but um
you know it's it's
a lot of people get turned on it later
in life there is there is going back
there is growing up if you want to call
it there is
maturation there is becoming a little
more normal-ish like basically what i
had to do to get this from my bar i had
to trade it for going to church so i'm
like okay deal
so you go to church now well i'm going
to yes i'm i'm putting down the uh the
the down payment soon so yeah i'm i'm uh
yes
all right
james thank you so much for sharing your
story you're welcome good luck with
whatever you do thank you thank you
you